cinquante quatre légendes du golf à
saint quentin en yvelines bienvenue aux
parisse les djeuns championship la
compétition était organisée pour la
seconde fois sur le parcours de
l'albatros avec un plateau d'exception
c'est une épreuve de deluz open senior
tour c'est la douzième épreuve je crois
de du calendrier de ce circuit
professionnel
c'est l'open de france seniors et puis
après on a des pointures mondiales comme
john delli comme paul broadhurst comme
costantino rocca voilà des joueurs qui
nous ont fait vibrer il ya quelques
années qui joue encore très très bien au
total plus de 4500 spectateurs se sont
rendus sur les greens du golf national
pour admirer ces champions c'est un très
joli tournoi avec des gens qu'on a
connus dali fin des grandes et grands
joueurs et masi colvert enfin j'ai bien
aimé jusqu'à maintenant j'ai bien aimé
ça intéresse un public notamment
beaucoup de gens qui ont passé la
soixantaine joue encore au golf donc on
est toujours un peu concerné qu'il ya
des gens de notre âge qui joue encore et
qui joue aussi bien après trois jours de
compétition c'est finalement l'anglais
paul broadhurst qui remporte la
compétition 22 ans après avoir remporté
l'open de france à saint quentin en
yvelines avec un total de -12 il devance
la star américaine john delli de deux
coups rendez vous l'année prochaine pour
une troisième édition
[Applaudissements]